now if you drive on the 95 right near
downtown las vegas
brace yourself some big time traffic in
the coming months a major freeway fix-up
project now underway between the
spaghetti bowl and eastern avenue
two lanes will be shut down for over a
year
joe moeller live near the spaghetti bowl
with what you can expect in an already
busy area joe
that's right this all started this
weekend will be going on for a year and
a half take a live look here at the 95
southbound lanes here at this hour
people trying to get home
you can see this is where the lane
closure starts and it just backs up all
the way
way past this point way west of downtown
las vegas we spoke to people who live in
this area earlier and they are not
looking forward to this next year and a
half
it's a real cluster of a mess highway 95
near downtown las vegas is going to be a
little tight for some time
it's going to be bad for a while both
sides of the 95 will be squeezing down
to two lanes between the spaghetti bowl
and eastern
ndot says they will be repairing
repaving and adding a lane to the
southbound side
neighbors know the work needs to be done
and all them hold like it
is bad for cars man especially if you
got rims and
stuff like that it will wear and tear on
your cars the 40 million dollar project
starts this week and goes through
december of 2022.
john already got caught up in the
traffic it's going to take me 15 to 20
minutes
just to get on there because the traffic
has backed up so much
several ramp closures will take place
too the casino center exit on the
southbound side will be closed through
september
i try to avoid that as much as possible
just because of the confusion
that it is now but now they're doing
construction i'm going to go around
and dodd is urging people to try and
take other routes now that i see
just firsthand just yesterday what i see
and it hasn't really even started yet
i'll avoid it with all costs
now back out here live you're taking
another look at the southbound lanes of
the 95 this is just before casino center
so a lot of people
don't know about that off-ramp closure
but there will be other ones you can
actually get updates
regarding this project sent straight to
your phone we have a link for you to do
that up on our website eightnewsnow.com
reporting live near downtown las vegas
joe mohler 8 news now